Wednesday May 30th towards nine o'clock
in the morning we the judges repaired to
the place of the Old Market in Rouen we
were assisted by the Reverend Father in
Christ the Lord's Bishop of theru and
Noah and by a number of other laws
masters and ecclesiastical personages
before us was brought the Serge Joan in
presence of the people assembled in this
place in an immense multitude she was
placed upon a scaffold or platform for
her wholesale admonition and for the
edification of the whole multitude a
solemn address was made by the renowned
dr. Nicholas MIDI who took for his text
those words of the Apostle in the First
Epistle to the Corinthians chapter 12 if
one member suffer all the members suffer
with it
[Music]
this address ended we the bishop did
once more admonish joan to look to her
salvation to reflect on her misdeeds to
repent of them to have a true contrition
for them
we exhorted her to believe here on the
opinion of the clergy of the notable
persons who have taught and instructed
her on all the truths of her salvation
we did particularly exhort her to
believe the good advice of the to
venerable Dominicans who were that
moment beside her and whom had sent to
her to converse with her up to the last
moment and to furnish her in all surety
with wholesome admonitions and counsels
profitable to her salvation afterwards
we the bishop and vicar aforesaid having
regard to all that has gone before in
which it is shown that this woman had
never truly abandoned her errors her
obstinate temerity nor her unheard of
crimes that she had even shown the
malice of her diabolical obstinacy in
this deceitful semblance of contrition
penitence and amendment malice rendered
still more damnable by perjury of the
Holy Name of God and blasphemy of his
ineffable majesty considering her on all
these grounds obstinate incorrigible
heretic relapsed into heresy and
altogether unworthy of the Grace and of
the communion which by our former
sentence we did mercifully Accord to her
all of which being seen and considered
after mature deliberation and counsel of
a great number of doctors we have at
last proceeded to the final sentence on
these terms in the name of the Lord amen
at all times when the poison the virus
of heresy attaches itself with
persistence to a member of the church
and transforms him into a member of
Satan extreme care should be taken to
watch that the horrible contagion of
this pernicious leprosy
do not gain other parts of the mystic
body of Christ the decisions of the Holy
Fathers have willed that hardened
heretics should be separated from the
midst of the just similar to the great
peril of others this homicidal Viper
should not be warmed in the bosom of the
pious Mother Church it is for this that
we Pierre by the Divine Mercy Bishop of
Beauvais
and we brother Jean Lemaitre deputy of
the renowned dr. Jean Rivera Inquisitor
of the evil of heresy specially
delegated for him by this process both
judges competent in this trial already
by a just judgment have declared this
woman fallen into diverse errors and
diverse crimes of schism idolatry
invocation of demons and many others but
because the church closes not her bosom
to the child who returns to her we did
think that with a pure spirit and of
faith unfeigned you has put far from the
thy errors and thy crimes considering
that on a certain day you did renounce
them and did publicly swear vow and
promise never to return to thy errors
and heresies to resist all temptations
and to remain faithfully attached to the
unity of the Catholic Church and the
communion of the Roman pontiff as is
proved at greater length in a writing
signed by your own hand but after this
Abbe duration of your errors the author
of schism and heresy had arisen in your
heart which he had once more seduced and
it became manifest by thy spontaneous
confessions and assertions Oh shame
that as the dog returns again to his
vomit so you have returned to your
errors and
crimes
[Music]
and it had been proved to us in a most
certain manner that you have renounced
the guilty inventions and thy errors
only in a lying manner not in a sincere
and faithful spirit for these causes
declaring the fallen again into thy old
errors and under the sentence of
excommunication which you have formerly
incurred we decree that you are a
relapsed heretic by our present sentence
which seated in tribunal we utter and
pronounce in this writing we denounce
thee as a rotten member and that you may
not vitiate others as cast out from the
unity of the church separate from her
body abandoned to the secular power as
indeed by these presence we do cast thee
off separate and abandon the praying
this same secular power so far as
concerns death and the mutilation of the
limbs to moderate its judgment towards
thee and if true signs of penitence
should appear in the to permit that the
Sacrament of Penance be administered to
thee
[Music]